Although
many describe shoddy workmanship or a hasty,
temporary repair as jerry-rigged, in its original
incarnation, the term was actually jury-rigged.
While jury as a noun meaning a group of peers
that decide the outcome of a legal proceeding
has been in use English since the early 14th
century, by the early 17th century, sailors
had taken to using jury as an adjective that
meant temporary / hastily contrived, first
referring to jury-masts.
It is unclear why, however, and unfortunately
all we have are speculative hypotheses with
nothing in the way of evidence backing them
up.
One such hypothesis is that French speaking
sailors had been describing their quick repairs
as ajurie, which meant help or relief, and
English speakers mistakenly assumed they were
saying jury.
Perhaps slightly more plausible is that it
was originally joury mast, meaning “day
mast” (from the French “jour” meaning
“a day”)- essentially a temporary mast
meant to only last a short while.
Yet another speculative hypothesis is that
the term came about because it took a jury
of sailors to put their heads together to
come up with a way to create a usable make-shift
mast.
Whatever the case, sailors were calling the
temporary masts they rigged up to replace
those lost in storms as jury-masts from at
least the early 17th century, with the term
first appearing in Captain John Smith’s
1616 work A Description of New-England, “We
had reaccommodated her a Iury mast, and the
rest, to returne for Plimouth.”
He later used the term again in his The General
History of Virginia, New-England, and the
Summer Isles, published in 1624.
Captain Smith’s 1627 Seaman’s Grammar
also explicitly gives us a proper definition,
A Iury Mast, that is, when a Mast is borne
by the boord, with Yards, Roofes, Trees, or
what they can, spliced or fished together
they make a Iury-mast.
By the middle of the 17th century, jury was
being appended to a variety of other words
to describe something hastily put together,
as well as to give a humorous connotation,
such as this from Third Advice (1667):
Guard thy Posterior least all be gone, Though
Jury-Masts, tho’hast Jury-buttocks none.
As for the exact expression in question, jury-rigged
first appeared in 1788 in Newte’s A Tour
in England & Scotland with “ships to be
jury rigged; that is, to have smaller masts
. . . than would be required for actual service.”
As for jerry-rigging, it may be that jury
morphed into jerry via people just thinking
that’s what the expression was, though this
isn’t clear.
Jerry-X first popped up around 1856 in the
form of jerry-built, more or less meaning
“built of poor quality materials.”
A decade or so later, the variant jerrry-builder
made its debut to describe the makers of such
product.
In nearly all of these terms’ earliest usages,
they were referring to poorly constructed
homes or buildings.
For instance, in the 1881 work Every Man his
own Mechanic:”It is unfortunately too often
the habit of builders—or rather jerry builders—to
use the worst possible description of bricks.”
Unfortunately for connecting the dots, there
was not any associated jury-built term known
at this time, meaning it’s possible jerry-built
rose up independently.
It’s also worth noting that jerry-built
and jury-rig have slightly different connotations-
the former meaning something was purposefully
built of poor quality materials and the latter
meaning something poorly built out of necessity
in a pinch.
Given the lack of a clear etymology on this,
speculative origins abound.
Some hypothesize jerry in this sense may have
devolved from a weak and unlikable character
in the play The Mayor of Garratt (1820) whom
the author, Samuel Foote, named Jerry Sneak.
Another hypothesis is that it’s a shortened
version of “Jericho.”
Perhaps the leading hypothesis is that there
was some building company that included the
name Jerry in their business name and did
shoddy work.
In this case, it’s possibly the previous
similar sounding jury-x terms then inspired
the ironic connection to the name Jerry in
the company name.
However, as with the ultimate root of “jury-mast,”
these hypotheses are pure speculation with
no hard evidence backing
them up.